[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في غياب الوفد الحكومي
السوداني الاجتماع الرئاسي للجنه الايجاد
بشان الازمه يدعو طرفي الصراع الى وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار والاحتكام للحوار
الخارجيه السودانيه تتهم نيروبي بعدم
الحياه وتطالب بتغيير الرئاسه الكنيه
للجنه عشيه قمه النيتو في ليتوانيا بايدن
يبحث مع سوناك في لندن جهود دعم اوكرانيا
والسلطان يلمح الى امكانيه تقليص المراحل
المطلوبه من كييف للانضمام الى الحلف
بينما تحذر موسكو من عواقب وخيمه على
الامن الاوروبي في حال ضم اوكرانيا الى
النيتو روسيا تؤكد لاول مره حدوث اجتماعا
بين بوتين بعد خمسه ايام من تصعيد لم يعلن
ان الاجتماع امتد ثلاث ساعات وتضمن عروضا
لدمج المجموعه في المجال العسكري ويقول ان
قاده باجنر اكدوا تاييدهم للرئيس الروسي
نادي يوفنتوس الايطالي يتوصل الى اتفاق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم على تسويه
تبعد العقوبات الماليه عن الفريق وذلك
بعدم المشاركه في البطولات القاريه للموسم
المقبل الى اللقاء